so i apologize for distracting us we
were talking about heidegger okay that
uh
and the reason we were distracted is he
happened to also be a nazi but
he nevertheless has a lot of powerful
ideas what are the ideas he's brought to
the world okay so that's a big huge
question so
let me see how much of it i can get on
the table
i mean the the big picture is that
heidegger thinks and he's not really
wrong to think this
that the whole history of philosophy
from plato forward maybe even from the
pre-socratics forward from like the 6th
century bc
to now has
been motivated by a certain kind or has
been grounded on a certain kind of
assumption
that it didn't have the right to make
and that it's led us astray
and that until we understand
the way in which it's led us astray
we're not going to be able to get to
grips with the condition we now find
ourselves in so let me start with what
he thinks the condition we now find
ourselves in is
lots of periods to heidegger's views i'm
not i'm just going to sort of mush it
all together for the purposes of today
uh heidegger thinks that one of the
crucial
things that we need to contend with
when we think about
uh what it is to be us now
is that the right name for our age is a
technological age
and what does it mean for our age to be
a technological age
well it means that we have an
understanding
of what it is for anything at all to be
at all
that
we never really chose
that's sort of animating the way we live
our lives that's animating our
understanding of ourselves and
everything else that
is quite limited
and it's organized around the idea
that to be something
is to be
what's sitting there
as an infinitely flexible
reserve
to be optimized and made efficient
and heidegger thinks that uh that's
that's
not just the way we think of
silicon circuits
or you know the
the river when we put a hydroelectric
power plant on it we're optimizing the
flow of the river so that it makes
energy which is infinitely flexible and
we can use in any way at all it's the
way we understand ourselves
too
we think of ourselves as this reserve
of potential
that needs to be made efficient and
optimized and when i when i talk with my
students about it i ask them you know
like
what's your calendar look like
you know
what's the goal of your day
is it to get as many things into it as
possible is it to feel like i've i've
failed unless i've uh i've made my life
so efficient that i'm doing this and
this and this and this and this that i
can't let things go by
the feeling
that i think we all
have
that
there's some pressure to do that to
relate to ourselves that way
is a clue to what heidegger thinks the
technological age is about
and he thinks that's different from
every other age in history
we used to think of ourselves in the
17th century at the beginning of the
of the enlightenment as subjects
who
represent objects descartes thought
that a subject is something some mental
sort of realm that represents the world
in a certain way and we are closed in on
ourselves in the sense that
we have a special relation to our
representations
uh and that's that's what the realm of
the subject is but others you know in
the middle ages we were created in the
image and likeness of god in in in the
pre-socratic age to be was to be what
whooshes up and lingers for a while and
fades away the paradigm of of what is
where thunderstorms and
the anger of the gods the achilles
battle fury and it overtakes everything
and stays for a while and then leaves
the
the flowers blooming in spring and
that's very different
from the way we experience ourselves and
so the so the question is um what are we
supposed to do in the face of that and
heidegger thinks that's the
the presupposition that's motivated
everything
from the pre-socratics forward
is that
there is
some entity that's the ground
of the way we understand everything to
be
for the middle ages it was god that was
the entity that made things be the
things that they are
for the enlightenment it was us
maybe for sarge it's us
and heidegger thinks
um whatever it is that stands at the
ground of what we are is not another
thing it's not another entity and we're
relating to it in the wrong way if we
think of it like that
there's some way and he this is partly
why i was interested in meister eckhart
he says what there is is there's giving
going on
in the world
and we're
the grateful recipient of it
and the giving is like
whatever it is it's the social norms
that we're thrown into we didn't choose
them they were given to us and that's
the ground that is what makes it
possible for anything to be intelligible
at all if we lived outside of
communities if we lived in a world where
there were no social norms at all
nothing would mean anything
nothing would have any significance
nothing would be regular in the way that
things need to be regular in order for
there to be departures or manifestations
of that regularity uh so so community
norms are crucial
but they're also always updating
we place um we have some responsibility
for
what they are and the way in which
they're updating themselves
and yet we didn't ever choose it to be
that way
so those norms are somehow
giving
significance to us
in a way that that we're implicated in
we have some relation to and all that
gets covered over if you think of us as
efficient resources to be optimized
you